hi everyone welcome to lecture number
seven so up to now I believe can you
hear me in the back is it easy okay so
in the last set of module that you've
seen you've learnt about convolutional
neural networks and how they can be
applied to imaging notably
you've played with different types of
layers including pooling max pooling
average pooling and convolutional layers
you've also seen some classification
with the most classic algorithms all the
way up to inception and resonance and
then you jumped into advanced
application like object detection with
Yolo and the faster scan and faster our
CNN series with an optional video and
finally face recognition and your site
transfer that we talked a little bit
about in the past lectures so today
we're going to build on top of
everything you've seen in this set of
modules to try to delve into the neural
networks and interpret them because you
you noticed after seeing the set of
modules up to now that a lot of
improvements of the neural networks are
based on trial and error so we try
something we do hyper parameter search
sometimes the model improves sometimes
it doesn't we use a validation set to
find the right set of methods that would
make our model improve it's not
satisfactory from a scientific
standpoint so people are also searching
how can we find an effective way to
improve our neural networks not only
with trial and error but with theory
that goes into the network and
visualizations so today we will focus on
that we first will see three methods
saliency Maps occlusion sensitivity and
class activation maps which are used to
kind of understand what was the decision
process of the network given this output
how can we map back the output decision
on the input space to see which part of
the inputs were discriminative for this
output and later on we will delve even
more in details into the network by
looking at intermediate layers what
happens at an activation level at a
layer level and at the net
clever with another set of methods
gradient ascent class model
visualization data set search and
deconvolution we will spend some times
on the deconvolution because it's it's a
cool it's a cool type of mathematical
operation to know and it will give you
more intuition on how the convolution
works from a mathematical perspective if
we have time we go over a fun
application called deep dream which is
super cool visuals for some of you who
know it okay let's go menti code is on
the board if you guys need to sign up
so as usual we go over some contextual
information and in small case studies so
don't hesitate to participate so you've
built an animal classifier for a pet
shop and you gave it to them it's it's
super good it's been trained on imagenet
plus some other data and what what is a
little worrying is that the pet shop is
a little reluctant to use your network
because they don't understand the
decision process of the model so how can
you quickly show that the model is
actually looking at a specific animal
let's say your cut if I give it an input
that is a cat we've seen that together
one time already remembers so I go
quickly you have a network here's a dog
given as an input to a CNN the CNN
assuming the constraint is that there is
one animal per image was trained with
the softmax output layer and we get a
probability distribution over all
animals iguana dog car cats and in crap
and what we want is to take the
derivative of the score of dog and back
propagated to the input to know which
parts of the inputs were discriminative
for this score of dog does that make
sense everybody remembers this and so
the interesting part is that this value
is the same shape as X so it's the size
of the input it's a matrix of numbers if
the numbers are large in absolute value
it means the pixels corresponding to
these locations had an impact on the
score of duck okay what do you think the
score of dog is easy the output
probability R now what what do I mean by
s of
yep score on the dog it's a score of the
dog yeah but easy point 80 pipe that's
what I need yes it's the the score that
is pre soft max it's the score that
comes before the soft max so as you
reminder here's a a soft max layer and
this is how it could be presented so you
get us a vector that is a set of scores
that are not necessarily probabilities
they're just scores between minus
infinity and plus infinity you give them
to the soft max and the soft max what is
going to do is that is going to output a
vector where the sum of all the
probabilities in this vector are going
to sum up to one okay and so the issue
is if instead of using the derivative of
what we called Y hat last time we use
the score of dog we will get a better
representation here the reason is in
order to maximize this number score of
dog divided by the sum of the score of
all animals or like maybe I should write
exponential of score of dog divided by
sum of exponential of the score of all
animals one way is to minimize the
scores of all the other animals rather
than maximizing the score of dog so you
see so maybe moving a certain pixel we
minimize the score of fish and so this
pixel will have a high influence on Y
hats the general output of the network
but it actually doesn't have an
influence on the score of dog one layer
before does it make sense so that's why
we would use the scores pre soft max
instead of using the scores post soft
max that are the probabilities okay and
what's fun is here you cannot see
there's the sides are online if you want
to if you want to look at it on your
computers but you have some of the
pixels that are roughly the same
positions as the dog is on the input
image that are stronger so we see some
white pixels here and this can be used
to segment the dog probably
so you could use a simple trash holding
to find where the dog was based on this
pixel pixel there is the pixel score map
doesn't work too well in practice so we
have better methods to do segmentation
but this can be done as well so this is
what is called salience see maps and
it's a common technique to quickly
visualize what the network is looking at
in practice we will use other methods so
here's another contextual story now
you've built the animal classifier
they're still little scared but you want
to prove that the model is actually
looking at the input image at the right
position you don't need to be quick but
you have to be very precise ya know the
saliency map is literally this thing
here is the values of the derivative so
you you you take the score of dog you
back propagate the gradient all the way
to the input it gives you a matrix that
is exactly the same size as X and you
use you use like a specific color scheme
to see which pixels are the strongest
thank you okay so here we have our CNN
the dog is four propagated and you get a
score of probability score for the dog
now you want a method that is more
precise than the previous one but not
necessarily too fast and this one we've
talked about it a little bit it's
occlusion sensitivity so the idea here
is to put a gray square on the dog here
and we propagate this image with the
gray square at this position through the
CNN what we get is another probability
distribution that is probably similar to
the one we had before because the gray
square doesn't seem to impact too much
image it's at least from a human
perspective we still see a dog right so
the score of dog might be high 83%
probably what we can say is that we can
build a probability map corresponding to
the class dog and ha and we write down
on this map how confident is the network
if the gray square is that
testing location so for our first
location it seems that the network is
very confident so let's put a red square
here now I'm going to move the gray
square a little bit I'm shifting it just
as we do for convolution and I'm going
to send again this new image in the
network it's going to give me a new
probability distribution output and the
score of dog might change so looking at
this score of dog I'm going to say ok
the network is still very confident that
there is a dog here and I continue I
shift it again here same networks still
very confident that there is a dog
now I shift the square vertically down
and I see that partial that the the face
of the dog is partially occluded
probability of dog will probably go down
because the network cannot see one eye
of the dog is not confident that there
is a dog anymore
so probably the confidence of the
network went down I'm going to put a
square that is tending to be blue and I
continue I shift it again and here we
don't see the dog face anymore
so probably the network might might
classify this as a chair right because
the chair is more obvious than the dog
now and so the probability score of dog
might go down so I'm going to put a Blue
Square here and I'm going to continue
here we don't see the tail of the dog
it's still fine the network is pretty
confident and so on and what I will look
at now is this probability map which
tells me roughly where the dog is so
here we use the pretty big filter
compared to the size of the image the
smaller the sorry the pretty big gray
square the smaller the gray square the
more precise this probability map is
going to be does that make sense so this
is if you have time if you can you can
take your time with the pet shot to
explain them what's happening you would
do that yeah we will see that in the
next slide that's correct
so let's see more examples here we have
three classes and these these these
images has been have been generated by
much as I learned Rob Fergus this paper
visualizing and understanding
convolutional networks is one of the
seminal paper that has led the research
in in visualizing and interpreting
neural networks so I'd advise you to
take a look at it and we will refer to
it a lot of time in this lecture so now
we have three examples one is a
pomeranian which is this type of cute
dog a car wheel which is the true class
of the second image and napkin hound
which is this type of dog here on the
last image so if you do the same thing
as we did before that's what you would
see so just to clarify here we see a
blue color it means when the gray square
was positioned here or centered at this
location the network was less confident
that the true class was Pomeranian and
in fact if you look at the paper they
explained that when the gray square was
here the confidence of Pomeranian went
down because the cumference because the
confidence of tennis ball went up and in
fact the Pomeranian dog has a tennis
ball in the mouth another interesting
thing to notice is on the last picture
here you see that there is a red color
on the top left of the image and this is
you exactly at what as what you
mentioned Adam is that when the square
was on the face of the human the network
was much more confident than the true
class that the true class was the dog
because we removed a lot of meaningful
information for the network which was
the face of the human and similarly if
you put the square on the dog the true
class that the network was outputting
was human problem that makes sense ok so
this is called occlusion sensitivity and
it's the second method that you now have
seen for interpreting word the network
looks at on an input so let's move to
class activation Maps so I know if you
remember but two weeks ago
Pranav when he discussed the techniques
that he has you
in healthcare he explained that you get
a he get a chest x-ray and he manages to
to tell the doctor where the network is
looking at when predicting a certain
disease based on this chest x-ray right
remember that so this was done through
class activation labs and that's what
we're going to see now so one important
thing to notice is that we discussed
that classification networks seem to
have a very good localization ability
and we can see it with the two methods
that we previously discussed same thing
for those of you who have read the
yellow paper that you've studied in this
set of modules the yellow v2 algorithm
has first been trained on classification
because classification has a lot of data
a lot more than object detection has
been trained on classification built a
very good localization ability and then
has been fine-tuned and retrained on
object detection data sets okay and so
the core idea of class activation map is
to show that CNN's have a very good
localization ability even if they were
trained only on image level labels so we
have this Network there is a very
classic Network used for classification
we give it a kid and a dog this class
activation map is coming from MIT MIT
lab with Balaji at all in 2016 and you
for propagate this image of a kid with a
dog through the network which has some
comic spool classic series of layers
several of them and at the end you
usually flatten the last output volume
of the comp and run it through several
fully connected layer which are going to
play the role of a classifier and send
it to a soft Max and get the probability
output now what we're going to do is
that we're going to prove that this CNN
is generalizing to localization so we're
going to convert this same network in
another network and the part which is
going to change is only the last part
the downside of using flattened plus
fully connected is that you lose all
spatial information right
you have a volume that has spatial
information although it's been gone
through some max pooling so it's been
down sampled and you lost some part of
the special localization flattening
kills it you flatten it you run it
through a fully connected layer and then
it's over you it's it's super hard to
find out where the activation was
corresponds to on the input space so
instead of using flattened possibly
connected we're going to use global
average pooling we're going to explain
what it is a fully connected softmax
layer and get the probability output and
we're going to show that now this
network can be trained very quickly
because we just need to train one layer
the fully connected here and can show
where the network looks at the same as
the previous network so let's talk about
it more in detail assume this was the
last complex and it outputs a volume a
volume that is sized to simplify 4 by 4
by 6 so 6 filters were used in the last
comp and so we have 6 feature Maps now
that make sense I'm going to convert
this using a global average pooling to
just a vector of 6 values what is global
average pooling is just taking these
feature Maps each of them averaging them
into one number so now instead of having
a 4 by 4 by 6 volume I have a 1 by 1 by
6 volume but we can call it a vector now
that makes sense
so what's interesting is that this
number actually holds the information of
the whole feature map that came before
in one number being averaged over it I'm
going to put these in a vector and I'm
going to call them activations as usual
a 1 a 2 a 3 a 4 a 5 a 6 as I said I'm
going to train a fully connected layer
here with the softmax activation and the
outputs are going to be the
probabilities so what is interesting
about that is that the feature Maps here
as you know will contain some visual
patterns so if I look at the first
feature map I can plot it here so these
are the values and of course this one is
much more granular than 4 by 4 it's not
a 4 by 4 it's much more
but this you can say that this is the
feature map and it seems that the
activations have found something here
there was a visual pattern in the input
that activated the feature map and the
filters which generated this feature map
here in this location same for the
second one there is probably two objects
or two patterns that activated the
filters that generated this feature map
and so on so we have six of those and
after I've trained my fully connected
layers here my fully connected layer I
look at the score of dog score of dog is
91% what I can do is to know this 91%
how much did it come from these feature
maps and how can I know it is because
now I have a direct mapping using the
weights I know that the weight number
one here this edge you see it is how
much this score was dependent on the
orange feature map that make sense the
second weight if you look at the green
edge is the weights that has multiplied
this feature map to give birth to the
output of a dog so this weight is
telling me how much this feature map the
green one has influence on the output
that make sense so now what I can do is
to sum all of this a weighted sum of all
these feature Maps and if I just do this
weighted sum I will get another feature
map something like that and you notice
that this one seems to be highly
influenced by the green one the green
feature map yeah it means probably the
weight here was higher it probably means
that the second filter of the last comp
was the one that was looking at the dog
that make sense okay and then once I get
this feature map this feature map is not
the size of the input image right it's
the size of the height and width of the
output of the last comp so the only
thing I'm going to do is like I'm going
to up Sam
back simply so that it fits the size of
the input image and I'm going to overlay
it on the input image to get my class
activation the reason it's called class
activation map is because this feature
map is dependent on the class you're
talking about if I was using let's say I
was using car here if I was using car
the weights would have been different
right look at the edges that connect the
first activation to the activation of
the previous layer these weights are
different so if I sum all of these
feature Maps I'm going to get something
else does that make sense so this is
class activation mass and in fact there
is a dog here and there's a human there
and what you can notice is probably if I
look at the class of human the weights
number one might be very high because it
seems that this visual pattern that
activated the first feature map was the
face of the kid okay so what is super
cool is that you can get your network
and just change the last few layers into
global average pooling plus the softmax
fully connected layer and you can do
that and visualize very well it requires
a small fine tuning yeah so it's a
different vocabulary I would use
failures see maps for the
backpropagation up to the pixels and
class activation maps related to one
class it's not a back propagation at all
it's just not sampling to the to the
input space based on the feature maps of
the last compilation mostly just
examining the weights that are doing
like a max operation not so much of a
background obligation yes any other
questions on class activation maps that
it's not
yeah that's a good question so taking
the average does it kill the spatial
information so let me let me write down
a formula here this is the score that
we're interested in let's say dog class
see what you could say is that this
score is a sum of k equal 1 to 6 fw k
which is the the weight that that
connects the output activation to the
previous layer times what times a of the
previous layer let's say we use a
notation that is like k is the chase
feature map and i j is the location and
I sum that over the locations can you
see in the back roughly so what I'm
saying is that here I have my global
average pooling that happened here and I
can divide it by the certain number so
divided by 16 4x4 okay I can switch the
two sums so I can say that this thing is
a sum over I J the locations times sum
over k equals 1 to 6 of what W K times H
a so the activations of the case feature
map in position H I J and times the
normalization 116 doesn't make sense
does this make sense so I still have the
location I still moved
I still move the sum around and what I
could do is to say that this thing is
the score in location IJ of the class
activation up is the class score for
this location IJ and I'm summing it over
all locations so just by flipping what
the average pooling was doing over the
locations I can say that by weighting
using my weights all the activation
in a specific location for all the
feature maps I can get the score of this
position in regards to the final output
does that make sense so we were not
losing the the spatial information the
reason we're not losing it is because we
know we know what the feature maps are
right we know what they are and we know
that they've been averaged exactly so we
exactly can map it back because we
assume that each filter that generated
this feature Maps detects one one
specific thing so like if if this is the
feature map it means assuming the filter
was detecting dog that we're going to
see just just something here meaning
that there is a dog here and if there
was a dog on the lower part of the image
we would also have strong activations in
this part I'd say if you want to see
more of the math behind it check the
papers but this is the intuition behind
it you can flip the summations using the
global average pooling and show that you
keep the spatial information the thing
is you do the global average pooling but
you don't lose the future maps because
you know where they were from the output
of the count right so you're not you're
not deleting this information that make
sense yeah the average yeah okay let's
move on and watch a full video on how a
class activation not work
this video was from Kylie McDonald
and it's it's life so it's very quick so
you can see that the network is looking
at the speedboat okay so now the three
methods we've seen are methods that are
roughly mapping back the output to the
input space and helping of visualize
which part of the inputs were the most
discriminative to lead to this output
and the decision of the network now
we're going to try to delve more into
details in the in the in the
intermediate layers of the network and
try to interpret how does the network
see our world not necessarily related to
a specific input but in general okay so
the pet shop now trust your model
because you've used origin sensitivity
salient see map and class actuation maps
to show that the model is looking at the
right place but they got a little scared
when you did that and they asked you to
explain what the model thinks a dog is
so you have this trained convolutional
neural network and you have an output
probability yep let me take one non
image data that's that's a good question
it's actually so the reason we're seeing
images what most of the research has
been focusing on images if you look at
electric time series data
so either speech or natural language the
main way to visualize those is with the
attention method are you familiar with
that so in the next set of modules that
you're going to start this week and
you're going to study in the next two
weeks you will see a visualization
method called attention models which
will tell you which part of a sentence
was important let's say to output a
number like assuming you're doing
machine translation you know some
languages they don't have a direct
one-to-one mapping it means I might say
I love cats but in another language
maybe this same sentence would be
attached I love or something it's fit
and you want an attention model to seek
to show you that the cat was referring
to the second I think it's okay sorry
guys
so going back to the presentation now
we're going to delve into inside the
network and so the new thing is the pet
shop is little scared and ask you to
explain what the network think a dog is
what's the representation of dog for the
network so here we're going to use a
method that we've already seen together
called gradient ascent which is defining
an objective that is technically the
score of the dog - a regularization term
what the regularization term is doing is
it's saying that X should look natural
it's not necessarily l2 regularization
can be something else and we will
discuss it in the next slide but don't
think about it right now what we will do
is we will compute the back propagation
of this objective function all the way
back to the input and perform gradient
ascent to find the image that maximizes
the score of the dog so it's an
iterative process takes longer than the
class activation map and we repeat the
process forward propagate X compute the
objective back propagate and update the
pixels and so on you guys are familiar
with that so let's see what what what we
can visualize doing that so actually if
you take an image net classification
network and you perform this on the
classes of goose or ostrich or Kitfox
Husky Dalmatians you can see what the
network is looking at or what the
network think that almassian is so for
the Dalmatian you can see some some
black dots on a white background somehow
but these are still quite hard to
interpret it's not super easy to see and
even worse here on the screen better on
your computers but you can see a fox
some here you can see orange color for
the fox it means that pushing the pixels
to an orange color would actually lead
to a higher score of the kid fox in the
output
if you use a better regularization than
l2 you might get better pictures so this
is for flamingo this is for Pelican and
this is for Hartley's so a few things
that are interesting to see is that in
order to maximize the score of flamingo
what the network visualized is many
flamingos it means that ten flamingos
leads to a higher score of the class
salmon go than one flamingo for the
network talking about regularization
what does l2 regularization say it says
that for visualising we don't want to
have extreme values of pixel it doesn't
help much to have one pixel with an
extreme value one pixel with a low value
and so on so we're going to regularize
all the pixels so that all the values
are around each other and then we can
rescale it between 0 and 20 255 if you
want one thing to notice is that the
gradient ascent process doesn't
constrain the inputs to be between 0 and
255 you can go to plus infinity
potentially while an image is stored
with numbers between 0 and 255 so you
might want to clip that as well this is
another type of regularization one thing
that led to beautiful pictures was what
Jason your sinski and his team did is
they for propagated an image computed
the score computed the objective
function back propagated updated the
pixels and blurred them blurred the
picture because what what is not useful
for visualizing is if you have high
frequency variation between pixels it
doesn't help to visualize if you have
many pixels close to each other that
have many different values instead you
want to have a smooth transition among
pixels and this is another type of
regularization called Gaussian blur Inc
ok so this method actually makes a lot
of sense in in in scientific terms
you're you're maximizing an objective
function that gives you what the network
sees as flamingo which would maximize
the score of flamingo
so we call it also class model
visualization yes
a more realistic class model
visualization correspond to more
accurate so it's hard to map the
accuracy of the model based on this
visualization it's a good way to
validate that the network is looking at
the right thing yeah we're going to see
more of this later I think the most
interesting part is actually on this
slide is we did it for the class score
but we could have done it with any
activation so let's say I stopped in the
middle of the network and I define my
objective function to be this activation
I'm going to back propagate and find the
input that will maximize this activation
it will tell me what is this activation
what does this activation fire for so
that's even more interesting I think
than looking at the input and then yep
does that make sense that we could do it
on any activation yep any questions on
that
okay so now we're going to do another
trick which is dataset search it's
actually one of the most useful I think
not fast but very useful
so the petrov loved the previous
technique and asks if there are other
alternatives to to show what what an
activation in the middle of a network is
thinking you take an image for
propagated through the network get your
output now what you're going to do is
select a feature map let's say this one
we're at this layer and the feature map
is of size 5x5 by 256 it means that the
complan had 256 filters right you're
going to look at these feature maps and
select probably yeah what you're going
to do select one of the feature maps
okay we select one out of 256 it feature
map and we're going to run a lot of data
for propagated to the network and look
which data points have had the maximum
activation of this feature map so let's
say we do it with the first feature map
we notice that these are the top five
images that really fired this feature
map like high activations on the fibula
what it tells us is that's probably this
feature map is detecting shirts could do
the same thing let's say we take the
second feature map and we look which
data points have maximized the
activations of this feature map out of a
lot of data and we see that this is what
we got the top five images probably
means that the other feature map seems
to be activated when seeing edges so the
second one is much more likely to appear
earlier in the network obviously than
later so one thing that you may ask is
this images sim crop like I don't think
that this was an image in the dataset is
probably a sub part of the image what do
you think this crop corresponds to
any idea how we cropped the image and
why these are cropped
like what why didn't I show you the full
images how was I able to show you the
cropped back anything that's correct
so let's say we pick an activation an
activation in the network this
activation for a convolutional neural
network often time doesn't see the
entire input image right doesn't see it
what it sees is a subspace of the inputs
image that make sense so let's look at
another slide here we have a picture of
unis 64 by 64 by 3 it's our inputs we
run it through a five layer confidence
and now we get an encoding volume that
is much smaller in height and width but
bigger in depth if I tell you what this
activation is seeing if you map it back
you look at the stride and the filter
size you've used you could say that this
is the part that this interesting
this-this-this activation is same it
means the pixel that was up there had no
influence on this activation and it
makes sense when you think of it you're
the easiest way to think about it is
looking at the the top picks the top
entry on the encoding volume top left
entry you have the input image you put a
filter here this filter gives you one
number right this number this activation
only depends on this part of the image
but then if you add a convolution after
it it will take more filters and so the
deeper you go the more part of the image
the activation will see so if you look
at an activation in layer 10 it will
seem much a much larger part of the
input than an activation in layer 1 that
make sense so that's why that's why
probably the pictures that I showed here
these ones are very small part crops
small crops of the image which means the
activation I was talking about here is
probably earlier in the network it sees
a much smaller part of the input
the final image nice what a nice one
pixel exact is going to respond to one
daily part the image with the pipe yeah
yeah so what you look at is which
activation was maximum you look at this
one and then you match this one back to
crop it make sense ok so here's again up
and same this one would correspond more
in the center of the image this
intuition make sense ok good so let's
talk about deconvolution now it's gonna
be the hardest part of the lecture but
probably helping with with more
intuition on the convolution you
remember that that was the generative
add virtual networks scheme and we said
that giving a code to the generator the
generator is able to output an image so
there is something happening here that
we didn't talk about is how can we start
with a 100 dimensional vector and now to
put a 64 by 64 by 3 image that seems
weird we could use you might say a fully
connected layer with a lot of neurons
right to up sample in practice this is
one method another one is to use a
deconvolution network so convolutions
will encode the information in a smaller
volume in heightened with deeper in in
depth while the deconvolution will do
the reverse it will up sample the height
and width of an image so that would be
useful in this case another case where
it would be usefully segmentation you
remember our case studies for
segmentation lifecell microscopic images
of cells give it to a convolution
Network it's gonna encode it so it's
gonna lower the height and width the
interesting thing about this encoding in
the middle is that it holds a lot of
meaningful information but what we want
ultimately is to get a segmentation mask
and the segmentation mask in height and
width has to be the same size as the
pixel image so we need
volution Network - up sample it so the
conversion are used in these cases today
the case we're going to talk about is
visualization remember the gradient
ascent method we talked about we define
an objective function by choosing an
activation in the middle of the network
and we want the objective to be equal to
this activation to find the input image
that maximizes its activation through an
iterative process now we don't want to
use an iterative process we want to use
reconstruction of this activation
directly in the input space by one
backward path so let's say I select this
feature map out of the max book 255
sorry 5x5 by 256 what I'm going to do is
I'm going to identify the max activation
of this feature map here it is is this
one third column second row I'm going to
set all the others to zero just this one
I keep it because it seems that this one
has detected something don't want to
talk about the others I'm going to try
to reconstruct in the input space what
this activation has fired for so I'm
going to compute the reverse
mathematical operation of pooling relu
and convolution I will pull I will
unreal you let's say doesn't like this
word doesn't exist so don't use it but
unreal ooh and decomp and I will do it
several times because this activation
went through several of them so I will
do it again and again until I see all
this specific activation that I selected
in the feature map fired because it
showed the ears of the duck and as you
see this image is cropped again it's not
the entire image it's just the part that
the activation has seen and if you look
at where the activation is located on
the feature map it makes sense that this
is the part that corresponds to it so
now the higher-level intuition is this
we're going to delve into it and see
what do we mean by and pull what do we
mean by unreal oh and what do we mean by
decock okay
yes you're at the mall and whatever
values they were at what we have just
gone and I read the instruction of the
whole image so the difference I mean if
we don't zero out all the activations it
says that this through construction
would be Messier
it would be more messy doesn't doesn't
necessarily mean you will not get the
full image because probably the other
activations probably didn't even fire it
means they didn't detected anything else
it's just that it's gonna is going to
add some noise to this reconstruction
okay so let's talk about the convolution
a little bit on the board so to start
with the convolution and you guys can
take notes if you want we're going to
spend about 20 minutes on the board now
to discuss the convolution okay to
understand the deconvolution we first
need to understand the convolution we've
seen it from a computer science
perspective but actually what we're
going to do here is we're going to frame
the convolution as a simple matrix
vector mathematical operation I'm going
to see that it's actually possible so
let's start with a 1d come for the 1d
convolution I will take an input X which
is of size 12 X 1 X 2 X 3 X 4 X 5 X 6 X
7 X 8 so 8 plus 2 padding which gives me
the 12 that I mentioned so the input is
a one-dimensional vector which has
padding of 2 on both sides I will give
it to a layer that will be a 1d comm and
this layer will have only one filter and
the filter size
we'll be four we will also use a stride
equal to two so my first question is
what's the size of the output can you
guys compute it on your on your notepad
and and tell me what's the size of the
output input size twelve filter of size
four stride of two padding of to fight
yeah I heard yeah so remember you use an
X sorry
n y equals n X minus F plus two T
divided by stride and you will get five
so what I'm gonna get is y1 y2 y3 y4 y5
so I'm going to focus on this specific
convolution for now and I'm going to
show now that we can define it as a as a
mathematical operation between a matrix
and a vector so the way to do it is I
guess the easiest way is to write the
system of equation that is underlying
here what is y1 y1 is the filter applied
to the four first values here does it
make sense so if I define my filter as
being Y W 1 W 2 W 3 and W 4 what I'm
gonna get is that Y 1 equals W 1 times 0
plus W 2 times 0 plus W 3 times X 1 plus
W 4 times X 2 this makes sense just a
convolution element-wise operation and
then sum all of it
why to is going to be same thing but we
just ride off to going to down so he's
going to give me W 1 times X 1 plus W 2
times X 2 plus W 3 times X 3 plus W 4
times X 4 correct everybody's following
know same thing we will do it for all
the wise until Y 5 and we know that Y 5
is element wise operation between the
filter and the 4 last number here
summing them so it will give me W 1
times X 7 plus W 2 times X 8 plus 0 plus
W 3 times 0 plus W 4 times 0 ok now what
we're going to do is to try to write
down Y as a matrix vector operation
between W and X we need to find what
this W matrix is and looking at the
system of equation it seems that it's
not impossible so let's try to do it I
will write my Y vector here y 1 y 2 y 3
y 4 y 5 and I will write my matrix here
and my vector X here so first question
is what do you think will be the shape
of this W matrix
five by twelve correctly we know that
this is five by one this is 12 by one so
of course W is going to be 5 by 12 right
so now let's try to fill it in 0 0 X 1 X
2 X 3 blah blah blah x800 can you guys
see in the background oh yeah ok cool so
I'm going to fill in this matrix
regarding this system of equation I know
that the y1 would be W 1 times 0 W 2
times 0 W 3 time X 1 w 4 times X so this
vector is going to multiply the first
row here so I just have to place my w's
here W 1 will come here multiply 0 w 2
will come here W 3 would come here and W
4 would come here and all the rest would
be filled in with zeros right I don't
want any more multiplications how about
the second row of this matrix I know
that Y 2 has to be equal to this dot
product with this rope and I know that
it's going to give me W 1 X 1 plus W 2 X
2 plus W 3 X 3 X 1 is the third input on
this vector third third entry so I would
need to shift what I had in the previous
row with the stride of 2 it will give me
that does it make sense so if I use the
dot product of this row with that I
should get the second equation up there
and so on and you understand what
happens right this pattern we just shift
we just ride off to on the side so I
would get zeros here and I would get my
W 1 W 2 W 3 w 4 and then zeros and all
the way down here and all the way down
here what I we get is w 4 W 3 w 2 W 1
and zeros so the only thing I want to
mention here is that the convolution
operation as you see can be framed
as a simple matrix times a vector yes on
the right side the top row should it be
the left because that's going to fight
for the top row wide the zeros are on
the right side yes because I don't want
Y hat y1 to be dependent on X 3/2 X 8 so
I want this to be 0 multiplicate pliers
okay so why is this important for the
intuition behind the deconvolution in
the existence of the deconvolution is
because if we managed to write down y
equal WX we probably can write down X
equal W minus 1 Y if W is an invertible
matrix and this is going to to be our
deconvolution and in fact what's the
what's the shape of this new matrix
yes 12 by 5 we have 12 by one on one
side five by one on the other it has to
be 12 by 5 so it's flipped compared to W
so one thing we're going to do here is
we're going to make an assumption first
assumption is that W is an invertible
matrix and on top of that we're going to
make a stronger assumption which is that
W is an orthogonal matrix and without
going into the details here same as when
we proved Xavier initialization in
sections we made some assumptions that
are not always true this assumption is
not going to be always true one one
intuition that you can have is if I'm
using a filter that is assume the filter
is an edge detector so like plus 1 0 0
minus 1 in this case the matrix would be
orthogonal why a matrix that is
orthogonal means that if I take two of
the columns here I dot product them
together it should give me 0 same with
the rows you can see it so what's
interesting is that if the stride was
for there will be no overlap between
these two rows it would give me an
orthogonal matrix here let's try these
two but if I replace this W 1 by minus 1
0 0 plus 1 sorry plus 1 0 0 minus 1 and
minus plus 1 0 0 minus 1 you can see
that the dot product would be 0 the
zeros will multiply the ones and the
ones were multiplied the zeros give me a
0 dot prod so this is a case where it
works practices doesn't always work the
reason we're making this assumption is
because we want to make a reconstruction
right so we want to be able to
this w- one this this is invert and the
reconstruction is not going to be exact
but at a first-order approximation we
can assume that the reconstruction will
still be useful to us even if this
assumption is not always true in the
case where w is orthogonal i know that
the inverter of w is w transpose or
another way to write it is that for
orthogonal matrices w transpose time w
is the identity matrix so what it tells
me is that X is going to be W transpose
time y times y so let's see what we get
from that let me write down the main C
code so let's say now we have our X and
we want to regenerate our we will have
our Y and we want to generate our X
using this method so I would what I
would write is to understand the 1dd
comp we can use the following
illustrations where we have X here which
is 0 0 X 1 X 2 X 3 all the way down to X
8 okay and I will have my W matrix here
W transpose and my Y vector y1 y2 y3 y4
and y5 here and so I know that this
matrix will be the transpose of the one
I have here right so I can just write
down the transpose the transpose will be
w1 w2 w3 w-4 okay I will shifted
we destroyed of two and so on and this
whole thing will be w transpose so the
small issue here is that this in
practice is not is going to be very
similar to a convolution but because but
it's going to be a tiny little different
in terms of implementation another
question I might ask is how can we do
the same thing with the same pattern as
we have here it means the stride is
going from left to right instead of
going from up to down I'm going to
introduce that with the technique called
sub-pixel convolution and for those of
you who read papers in segmentation in
visualization often time this is the
type of convolution that is used for
reconstruction so let's see how it works
I just want to do the same operation but
instead of doing it we just try going
from up to down I want to do it from a
strike going from left to right what one
thing you want to you want to notice
here is that the two lines that I wrote
here are cropped and the reason is
because we're using a padded input here
we will just crop the two top lines and
same for the two last lines they will be
cropped look at that w1 we multiply y
one and this one we multiply Y two and
so on so this dot product will give me
w1 times one
but I don't want that to happen because
I want to get to padded zero here
so we just drop that in this matrix is
actually going to be smaller than it
seems and is going to generate my X 1
through X Y 8 and then I will pad the
top values in the bottom values okay
just the hack
so let's look at the subpixel
convolution I have my input and now we
do something quite fun I would perform a
sub-pixel operation on Y what does it
mean I will insert zeros almost
everywhere I would insert them and I
will get 0 0 Y 1 0 Y 2 0 Y 3 0 Y 4 0 Y 5
and 0 0 even more zero here so this
vector is just the vector Y with some
zeros inserted around it and also in the
middle between the elements of Y now why
is that interesting it trans resting
because I can now write down my
convolution by flipping my weight so let
me explain a little bit what happened
here what we wanted is in order to be
able to efficiently compute the
deconvolution the same way as we've
learnt to compute the convolution we
wanted to have the weights scattered
from left to right with the stride
moving from left to right what we did is
that we use a sub pixel version of Y by
inserting zeros in the middle and we
divided the stride by 2
so instead of having a stride of two as
we had in our convolution we have a
stride of one in our deconvolution so
notice that I shift my weights from one
at every step when I move from one row
to another second thing is I flipped my
weights I flipped my weight so instead
of having W 1 W 2 W 3 w 4 now I have W
for W 3 w 2 W 1 and what you could see
is looking at that first look at this
row the first row that is not cropped
the result of the dot product of this
row with this vector is going to be Y 1
times W 3 plus y 2 times W 1 yeah now
let's look what happened here I look at
my first row here the dot product of
this first room with my Y here is going
to be a sorry sorry we these two are
cropped is what in same here so looking
at my first non cropped row here as a
dot product with this vector what I get
is w 3 times y 1 plus W 2 sorry plus W 1
times y 2 so exactly the same thing as I
got there so these two operations are
exactly the same operations they're the
same thing you get the same results to a
different way of doing it one is using a
weird operation with strides going from
top to bottom and the second one is
exactly a convolution
these are convolution convolution plus
flipped weights insertion of zeros for
the subpixel version of Y
and on top of that padding here and
there so this was the hardest part okay
does it give more intuition on the
convolution here you know now how
convolution can be framed as a
mathematical operation between a matrix
and a vector and you know also that
under these assumptions the way we will
deconvolve is just by flipping our
weights dividing the stride by two and
inserting zeros if we just do that we're
deconvolve Inc four propagates in a
convolution the following way
you want to deconvolve just flip all the
weights insert zeros sub-pixel and
finally divide the stride and that's the
deconvolution it's a super complex thing
to understand but this is the intuition
behind it now let's try to have an
intuition of how it would work in two
dimension let me write it down why do we
use that because in terms of
implementation this is the same as what
we've been using here is very similar
while this one is another implementation
so you could do both the same is the
same operation but in practice this one
is easier to understand because it's
exactly the same operation of the
convolution with flipped weights
insertion of zeros and divide it right
that's why I wanted to show that when
yes assumption doesn't hold
yeah so oftentimes the assumption
doesn't hold but what we want is to be
able to sear a construction and if we
use this method we will still see our
construction practice if we had really W
minus one the reconstruction would be
much better but we don't so let me go
over to to the the 2d example we're
going to go a little over time because
we have two hours technically for one
hour and 50 minutes and and let me go
over the 2d X
and then we will answer this question on
why we need to make this assumption so
here is the interpretation of the 2d
deconvolution let me write it down here
the intuition behind the 2d become is I
get my input which is 5 by 5 and this I
call it x i4 propagate it's using a
filter of size 2 by 2 in a conflate and
astride of - this is my convolution what
I get so if you do 5 minus 2 plus the
padding which is 0 divided by 2 plus 1
oh I forgot the plus 1 here plus 1 and
you floor it so so 5 minus 2 divided by
2 gives you 3 divided by 2 plus 1
no actually it will give you 3 by 3 yeah
3 by 3 a Y of 3 by 3 that's what you get
and now this you call it Y what you're
going to do here is you're going to
deconvolve Y in order to deconvolve Y in
order to deconvolve it you're going to
use a stride of 1 and what we said is
that we need to divide the stride by 2
right so we need astride of 1 and the
filter will be the same two by two and
you remember that what we've seen is
that the feature is the same it's just
that is going to be flipped so you will
use a filter of Dubai to but flip
and now what do we get we hope to get a
five by five input which is going to be
our reconstructed X five by five input
and the way we're going to do it is this
is the intuition behind it yeah okay up
to my - thanks yeah five by five here
that's what we hope to reconstruct the
way we will do it is we will take the
filter s is two by two we will put it
here and we will multiply all the
weights of this filter by y1 1 all the
weights will be multiplied by y 1 1 so
we get four values here which are going
to be W 4 y 1 1 W 3 y 1 1 and so on now
I will shift this with the stride of 1
and I will put my filter again here and
I will multiply all the entries by Y 1 2
and so on and you see that this entry
has an overlap so it will it will it
will be updated at every step of the
convolution it's not like what happened
in the fourth pass so this is the
intuition behind the two deconvolution
3d same thing you have a volume here so
your filter is going to be a volume what
you're going to do is you're going to
put the volume here x 1 1 1 and so on
and then if you have a second filter you
would put it again on top of it and
multiply by 1 1 1 all the weights of the
filter and so on it's a little
complicated but this is the intuition
behind the convolution ok let's get back
to the lecture I'm going to take one
question here if you guys need
clarification
no worries you don't understand the
convolution fully is the important part
is that you get the intuition here and
you understand how we use it so let me
make a comment why do we need to make
this assumption and do we need to make
when we want to reconstruct like we're
doing here in the visualization we need
to make this assumption because we don't
want to retrain waits for the D
convolutional Network what we know is
that the activation we selected here on
the feature map is has gone through the
entire pipeline of the confidence so to
reconstruct we need to use the weights
that we already have in the confidence
we need to pass them to the
deconvolution and reconstruct if we're
doing the segmentation like we talked
about for the lifecell we don't need to
do this assumption we're just saying
that this is a procedure that is the D
convolution and we will train the
weights of the deconvolution so there is
no need to make this assumption it's
just we have a technique that is
dividing this right by one and inserting
zeroes and then beam we will train the
weights and we get an output that is an
AB sampled version of the input that was
given to it so there's two use case one
where you use the weights and one where
you don't in this case we don't want to
retrain we want to use the weights so
let's see let's see a version more
visual of the up sampling so we do the
subpixel image this is my image 4x4 i
insert zeros and I pad it I get a nine
by nine image I have my filter like that
and this filter will convolve I will it
would convolve over the input so I would
place it on my input and at every step I
would perform a convolution up I will
get a value here the value is blue
because as you can see the weights that
affected the output were only the blue
weights I would use a stride of one beam
now the weights that affect my input are
the green ones and so on and I would
just come valve as I do usually and so
on and now one step down I see that the
weights that are impacting my input are
the purple ones so I would put a purple
here and so on so I just do the
convolution like that and so so one
thing that is interesting here is that
the values that are blue in my out 6x6
output were generated only using the
blue values of the filter the blue
weights in the filter the ones that are
green were only used you were only
generated using the green values of my
filter so actually this subsample
sub-pixel
convolution or deconvolution could have
been done with for convolutions with the
blue weights green weights purple white
sand yellow weights and then just just
replaced such that the adjustment would
be the output
just put the output of each of these
comp and mix them to give out a 6x6
output only thing you need to know we
have an input 4x4 and we get an output
6x6 that's what we wanted we wanted to
of sample the image we can retrain the
weights or use the transport version of
them so let's see what happens now we
understood what what the curve was doing
so we're able to decomp what we need to
do is also to ampoule and to unreal ooh
fortunately it's easier than the decomp
so we're not going to do board work
anymore so let's see how uncool works if
I give you this input to the pool link
to a max pooling layer the output is
obviously going to be this one
42 is the maximum of these four numbers
assuming we're using a two-by-two filter
with right of two vertically and
horizontally 12 is the maximum of the
green numbers six is the maximum of the
red numbers and seven the orange ones
now question I give you back the output
and I tell you give me the input can you
give me the input or no no what why
you need you need you only keep the
maximum so you you lost all the other
numbers I don't know anymore the 0 1 and
minus 1 that's where the red numbers
here because they didn't pass through
the maximum so max pool is not
invertible from mathematical perspective
what we can do is approximate its invert
how can we do that spread it out that's
a good point we could spread out the the
6 among the 4 values that would be an
approximation a better way if we managed
to catch some values is to catch
something we call the switches we catch
the values of the maximum using a matrix
that is very easy to store of zeros and
ones and we pass it to the unpooled and
now we can approximate the inverse
because we know where 6 was we know
where 12 was we know where 40 2007 was
but it's still not invertible because we
lost all the other numbers think about
max pool back propagation it's exactly
the same thing these numbers 0 1 minus 1
they had no impact in the loss function
at the end because they didn't pass
through the for propagation so actually
with the switches you can have the exact
back propagation well you know that the
other values are going to be zeros
because they didn't affected the loss
during the forward propagation but that
make sense okay so this is max pooling
and pooling and max pooling and we can
use it with the switches you can
approximately yeah why don't we just
catch the whole origination quickly
could catch the entire thing but in
terms of back for back propagation in
terms of efficiency we would just use
the switches because it's enough for on
pulling you're right we could catch
everything but then it's cheating like
you you kept it so you just give it back
yep ok so now we know how I'm pulling
works let's look at the relevant so what
we need to do in fact is to pass the
switches and the filters back to the end
to Lindy count in order to reconstruct
switches are the matrix of zeros and
ones indicating where the maximum
were and filters are the filters that I
will transpose under this assumption on
the board okay and so on and so on and I
get my reconstruction I just need to
explain the rail you now I give you this
input to relu and I forward propagate it
what do we get all the negative numbers
are going to be equalized to 0 and the
others are going to be kept now let's
say I'm doing a back propagation through
Lu what do I get if I give you that this
is the gradients that are coming back
and I'm asking you what are the
gradients after the rally during the
back propagation how does the Rayleigh
behave in backdrop
Zero's which ones are zeros the
negatives are zeros do you agree the
negatives in this yellow matrix are
going to be zeros during the backdrop I
guess sure think always about what was
the influence of the input on the last
function and you will find out what was
the backpropagation look at this number
this number here - - did this number
have the fact that it was - - did it
have any influence on the last function
no it could have been -10 it could have
been -20 it's not going to impact the
last function so what do you think
should be the number here zero even if
the number that is coming back the
gradient is 10 so what do you think
should be the value backward output
same idea is Mac spending what we need
to do is to remember the switches
remember which of these values had an
impact on the loss we passed the
switches all these values here that are
kind of a y-you know this is a why all
these ones had no impact on the last
function so when you back from a gate
their gradient should be set to zero
it doesn't matter to update them it's
not gonna make the loss go down so these
are all zeros and the rest they just
pass why do they pass with the same
value because relu for positive numbers
was one so this number one here that
passed the rally during the for
propagation it was not modified its
gradient is going to be one that makes
sense so this is really backward now in
this reconstruction method we're not
going to use rayleigh back part we're
going to use something we call value D
confident let's say the reason we're not
the intuition between why we're not
using value backward is because what
we're interested in is to know which
pixels of the input positively affected
the activation that we're talking up so
what we're going to do is that we're
just going to do a rail you we're just
going to do a rally backward another
reason is when we reconstruct we want to
have the minimum influence from the
forward propagation because we don't
really want our reconstruction to depend
on the forward propagation we would like
our reconstruction to be unbiased and
just look at this activation reconstruct
what happened so that's what you're
going to use again this is a hack that
has been found through trial and error
and it's not going to be scientifically
viable all the time okay so now we can
do everything and we can reconstruct and
find out what was this activation
corresponds to it took time to
understand it but it's super fast to do
now just one path not iterative we could
do it with every layer so let's say we
do it with the first block of conv rail
you max pool I go here I choose an
activation I find the maximum activation
I set all the others to zero I
unpolluted I come and I find out the
reconstruction this
via activation was looking at edges like
that so let's delve into the phone and
see how we can visualize inside what's
happening inside the network so all the
visualization we're going to see now can
be found in Matthews dealers and Rob
fair uses paper visualizing
understanding convolutional networks I'm
going to explain what they correspond to
but check check out their papers if you
want to understand more into details so
what happens here is that on the top
left you have nine pictures these are
the crop pictures of the data set that
activated the first filter of the first
layer maximum so we have a first filter
on the first layer and we run all the
data sets and we recorded what are the
main pictures that activate this filter
these were the main ones and we did the
same thing for all the filters of the
first layer and there are nine times
nine of them there are a lot of them I
think in the bottom here you have the
filters which are the weights that were
plotted just take the filter plot the
weights this is doing this is important
only for the first layer when you go
deeper in your network the filter itself
cannot be interpreted it's super hard to
understand it here because the weights
are directly multiplying the pixels the
first layer weights can be interpretable
and in fact you see that the let's look
at the third one the third filter here
on the first row the third filter has
weights that are kind of diagonal like
one of the diagonals and in fact if you
look at the data that maximized these
filters activation the feature map
corresponding to this filter they're all
like cropped images that correspond to
diagonals that's what happens now the
deeper we go the more fun we have so
let's go results on a validation set of
50,000 images what's happened here is
they took 50,000 images
therefore propagated to the network they
recorded which image is the maximum the
one that maximized the activation of the
feature map corresponding to the first
filter of layer two second
filter and so on for all the filters
let's look at one of them we can see
that okay we have a circle on this one
it means that this the filter general
which generated the feature map
corresponding to this has been activated
through probably a wheel or something
like that so the image of the wheel was
the one that maximizes the activation of
this one and then we use the Dickens
method to reconstruct it any questions
on that yeah good question what if the
activation function is not relevant in
practice you would just use a backward
to reconstruct if it's damaged you would
use the same the same type of method and
you will try to approximate the
reconstruction okay let's go a little
deeper so now same layer two four
propagate all the images of the dataset
find the nine images that are the
maximum activate that lead to the
maximum activation of the first filter
these are plotted on top here what you
can see is like for this filter that is
the sixth row first filter features are
more environment to small changes so
this filter actually was activated too
many different types of circles spirals
wheels and so it's it's still activated
although the circles were different size
can go even deeper up third layer what's
interesting is that the deeper you go
the more complexity you see so at the
beginning we're seeing only edges now we
see much more complex figures you can
see a face here in this in this entry it
means that this filter activated for
when it's exist when it has seen a data
point that had this face then we were
constructed it cropped it on the face
the face is kind of red it means that
the more red it was the more activation
it led to and same top nine for layer
tree so these are the nine images that
actually led to the face these are the
nine images that maximize the at the
activation of the feature map
corresponding to that filter and so on
so here is a
you dishonor
normalization layers we can switch back
and forth between showing the actual
activations and showing images
synthesized to produce high active
easily he is giving his own image to the
network right now but the time we get to
the fifth convolutional layer the
feeders being computed represent
abstract concepts so these are the green
that after example in Italy this neuron
seems to respond to phases we can
further investigate this neuron by
showing a few different types of
information first we can artificially
create optimized images using new
regularization techniques initially the
one we thought the bus needs that
simulation showing his neuron fires in
response to a face and show this one is
that they also that the images are
training set to activate this neuron the
most as well as pixels from those images
most responsible for the high
activations computed via the
deconvolution DC that the convolution
rings feature response to multiple faces
in different locations and by looking at
the decon we can see that it would
respond more strongly if we had even
darker eyes and rosy lips we can also
confirm that it carries about the head
and shoulders that ignores the arms and
torso we can even see that it fires to
some extent for cat faces using back
prop or decon we can see that this unit
depends most strongly on a couple units
in the previous layer contour and not
about a dozen or so in conservation try
to track by where it's look at another
marriage neural net so what is this unit
doing from the top nine images we might
conclude that it fires four different
types of clothing but examining the
synthetic images shows that it may be
detecting not clothing per se but
wrinkles in the live plot we can see
that it's activated
my shirt and smoothing out half of my
shirt causes that hack with the
activations to decrease finally here's
another interesting neuron this one has
learned to look for printed text in a
variety of sizes colors and fonts this
is pretty cool
because we never asked the network to
look for wrinkles or text or faces the
only papers we provided were at the very
last layer so the only reason the
network learned features like text and
faces in the middle was to support final
decisions at that last layer for example
the text detector may provide good
evidence that a rectangle is in fact a
book seen on edge and detecting many
books next to each other might be a good
way of detecting a bookcase which was
one of the categories we trained the net
to recognize in this video we've shown
some of the features of the deep list
toolbox and a few of the things we've
learned by using it you can download it
yeah so they have a toolbox which is
exactly what you need right here and you
could test the toolbox on your model
takes time to get get it to run but but
if you want to visualize all the neurons
it's very helpful okay so let's go
quickly we'll spend about three minutes
on the optional deep dream one cause
it's fun and yeah feel free free to jump
in and ask questions so the Google and
the page the blog post is by Alexander
morte Vince F the idea here is to
generate art using this knowledge of
visualization and how they do that is
quite interesting then we take an input
for propagated to the network and I took
specs to declare that we called the
Dreamliner then we'll take the
activation and set the gradient to be
equal to these activations the gradient
at this layer and then back propagate
the gradient uniqua so earlier what we
do is that we define the new objective
function that was equal to an activation
and we try to maximize its objective
function who they doing it even stronger
then you take the activations and they
the gradients to be equal to the
activations and so the stronger the
activation the stronger is going to
become later on and so on and so on and
so on so they're trying to see what the
network is activating for and increase
even this activation so for propagate
the image set the gradient of the
dreaming layer to be code to
exaggeration but back propagate all the
way back to the inputs and update the
pixel of the image do that several time
and every time the activations will
change so you have to set again the new
activations to be the the gradients of
the green layer and back propagate and
also makes it you would see things
happening so it's hard to see here on
the screen but you would have a pig
appearing here you'd have like a tree
somewhere there and some animals and a
lot of animals are going to start
appearing in this cloud it's interesting
because it means let's say you see this
cloud here if the network thought that
this cloud looked a little bit like
regard so one of the the the feature
maps was which would be generated by the
filter that the textile would activate
itself a little bit because we set the
gradient to be equal to the activation
is going to increase the appearance of
the dog in the image and so on and then
you will see a dog appearing after a few
iterations it's quite fun and if you
zoom you see that type of thing so you
see a big snail it's kind of a pig with
a snail carapace camel bird dog dogfish
I advise you to like look at this on the
slides rather than on the screen but
it's quite fine and same like if you
give that type of image you would see
that because the network thought there
was like a tower a little bit you will
increase the networks confidence in the
fact that there is a tower by changing
the image and the tower will come out
and so on it's quite a cool yeah and if
you dream in lower layers obviously you
will see edges happening or patterns
coming because the lower layers seem to
detect an edge and then you will
increase its confidence in its edge so
it we between create an edge on the
image these are fine
deep dream on video
[Music]
what's funny
[Applause]
get some trippy on the side so one one
inside that is fun about it is if the
network and this is not only for D dream
it's also its most default gradient
assets let's say we have an output score
of the dumbbell and we define our
objective function to be the dumbbell
score and we try to find image that
maximizes the dumbbell we will see
something like that the interesting is
that the network thinks that the
dumbbell is a hand with a dumbbell
not only the number and you can see it
here you see the hands and the reason is
it has never seen a dumbbell alone so
probably image that there is no picture
of a dumbbell alone in a corner and
leave all that samba but instead it's
usually a human triangle with fire
okay so just to summarize what we've
learned today we are now able to answer
all the following questions
what part of the best way to go what is
the role of a given neuron feature layer
become whoa reconstruct search in the
data set what are the top images and who
gradient ascent check can we check what
the network focus is on occasion
sensitivity saliency map class
activation maps how does the network see
our world I would say gradient descent
maybe deep drains of cool stuff and then
what are the implications and use cases
of these visualizations you can use
segment C mapped assignments not very
useful given the new methods we have but
the convolution that we've seen together
is widely used for segmentation and
reconstruction also for generative a
virtual networks to generate images and
parts sometimes these visualization are
also helpful to detect if some of the
neurons in your network are dead so
let's then you have a network and you
use the tool box and you see that
whatever the input image you give some
feature maps or always dark it means
that the feature that generated the
feature map icon holding over the inputs
probably never detected anything so it's
not being even trained that's the type
of
like you can get okay thanks guys sorry
we'll wipe over time